um let's see who else we we can talk to
here
how about oh i don't know uh there's
some very
interesting folks here why don't we go
to cooper from south carolina
uh hello david uh it's my first time
calling
um so i have a couple concerns about
medicare for all
okay so with the current system um
i want to go to a doctor appointment
with a specialist doctor
and it's gonna take me like six months
to uh get seen because i'm on the
waiting list
okay this is a real scenario you're
currently on a waiting list that's a
six-month waiting list
yeah and what specialty is it
dermatology
um no it's actually a neurologist okay
having some like uh nerve issues um
so my fear is that in a system
uh that's medicare for all perhaps the
wait times would be much longer
and i'm concerned that um like
for example if the waitlist was like a
year a year and a half like that would
make the care a lot less valuable
yeah so um i was wondering like
what what's what do you think about that
yeah i actually just did a video about
this a week and a half ago
called um won't what was it something
like uh won't medicare for all
mean everybody's going to try to get
health care and it'll gum up the system
so there's a couple different things
first of all
as you are pointing out we already have
wait lists
and sometimes people have to wait for
things and so one aspect of this is when
you change a system
some people still have to wait it's
sometimes different people than the ones
that are waiting now and ideally
weight would be commensurate with
inversely related to the degree of
urgency for the visit that's that's
number one
number two you also over the long term
would be likely to reduce the need for
specialist visits
by treating a lot of things early a lot
of people now
forego going to a primary care doctor
at all because they either don't have
insurance or don't want to pay their
co-pay or whatever the case may be
so something that could be dealt with
without a specialist early
becomes a something that then you have
to go to a specialist for
and so i think that it's not uh these
are complex issues there's no question
and there's examples of when you expand
access you do
uh increase the demand at emergency
rooms and it increases wait times
there are examples of that i'm not
denying that and these are complex
issues
but generally speaking generally
speaking
it's it's much more nuanced than simply
well if a lot more people have
health care the waiting list that every
specialist will go up
yeah um i was thinking maybe um at least
for like
uh like you were saying like the primary
doctors
maybe you could have a medicare for all
system for that but then also have like
a
public option for like more of the
specialty doctors just that way
like if you actually need to get seen
for something you might be able to
yeah i've never heard of medicare for
all plus public option i've heard of
medicare for all plus private insurance
for those who prefer it
i think in most systems medicare for all
makes the public option not necessary
but
uh that's something i that would be
interesting to look at
okay thank you all right thank you so
much i appreciate it
very interesting questions that's going
to do it for us
for today but we will take calls again
now
in the biden era thanks to everybody who
joined me we will take a quick break and
be back with much more right after this